hi wir sind hier wieder für euch heute
bei ZDF heute live ich freue mich sehr
dass ihr dabei seid um heute mit uns zu
diskutieren die EU besser gesagt dass
EU-Parlament wird gerade erschüttert von
einem richtig großen
korruptions-skandal und obwohl die
Ermittlung noch relativ am Anfang stehen
ist derzeit schon ziemlich klar es geht
hier wohl um einen der größten
eu-skandale in der Geschichte die
Vorwürfe lauten unter anderem Geldwäsche
und Bestechung Katha das ist der
Wüstenstaat über den wir eigentlich
gerade immer eher im Kontext WM sprechen
soll ich mit teuren Geschenken und hohen
geldsum Einfluss im EU-Parlament gekauft
haben im Fokus steht vor allem derzeit
eine der Vizepräsidentin des
EU-Parlaments die Griechen Eva kaii sie
sitzt mit anderen Verdächtigen sogar
schon in Untersuchung Saft aber auch der
EU-Abgeordnete Markt Arabella rückt
gerade in den Fokus sein Haus wurde am
Samstagabend durchsucht und heute wurden
tatsächlich auch Räumlichkeiten des
EU-Parlaments in Brüssel durch
über diese Fälle aber auch darüber wie
anfällig generell die europäischen
Institutionen für Korruption sind
darüber wollen wir heute diskutieren und
zwar mit Michelle van hülton
Geschäftsführer und Organisation der
Organisation von Sparring transparent
sie international EU und den
EU-Abgeordneten Erik Marquardt und
Daniel Kaspari ihr habt Fragen an die
drei oder ihr wollt vielleicht einfach
eure Meinung zum Thema mit uns teilen
dann könnt ihr das wie immer hier ihr
könnt gerne mitdiskutieren und eure
Fragen stellen schreibt uns gerne hier
im Chat auf Youtube oder per Mail an ZDF
heute-live@zdf.de jetzt begrüße ich aber
erstmal die EU-Abgeordneten Erik
Marquardt und Daniel Caspari bei uns im
Stream hi und herzlich willkommen
guten Abend einen wunderschönen guten
Abend
Herr Marquardt sie sind Teil der grünen
Fraktion und Teil des EU-Parlaments wie
geschafft sind sie denn persönlich von
dem was da gerade ans Licht kommt
ich glaube man kann nicht überrascht
sein dass wenn es im Katar geht das auch
Korruption eine Rolle spielt aber
natürlich sind wir alle und das glaube
ich kann ich nicht dafür die Grünen
sagen sondern vielleicht auch für den
Kollegen mit sehr geschockt davon dass
es offenbar eine kriminelle Vereinigung
in EU-Parlament mindestens gab die sich
hat bestechen lassen und wodurch
potenziell dann eben demokratische
Entscheidung angegriffen wurden
Kollege hat zum Teil schon für Sie
mitgeantwortet ich frage sie trotzdem
noch mal sie sind Teil der Fraktion der
Europäischen Volkspartei also der
Christdemokraten im EU-Parlament wie
überrascht sind sie von dieser
Einflussnahme in ihrem Parlament
ja gut das Einflussnahme stattfindet der
ist normal aber was wir hier leben ist
ja keine Einflussnahme sondern klar
Korruption hier wurde wenn die Vorwürfe
stimmen und alle spricht im Moment dafür
eine Abgeordnete dafür bezahlt dass sie
politisch Einfluss nimmt sie wurde dafür
bezahlt wie sie abstimmt und das ist
einfach illegal das ist Korruption das
ist undemokratisch und das schadet uns
allen und das muss jetzt wirklich ohne
irgendwelche Vorbehalte aufgeräumt
werden
über die Folgen für das EU-Parlament
sprechen wir gleich noch im Detail jetzt
verschafft uns Gunnar Krüger aber
erstmal ein Überblick über die aktuellen
Geschehnisse
Brüssel Europa-Parlament die
Abgeordneten sind den Straßburg aber die
Polizei war da durchsuchte ein Büro
versiegelte weitere und beschlagnahmte
Computer
der Umfang ist erheblich es geht um
Korruption Geldwäsche kriminelle
Organisation auf europäischer Ebene
vielmehr sagt Belgiens
Staatsanwaltschaft nicht doch Medien
berichten etwa von Markt tarabella der
belgische Sozialdemokrat war mal
scharfer Kater Kritiker zuletzt meinte
er es einmal gut mit Katha
diese einseitigen negativen Äußerungen
über Kata sind für die künftige
Entwicklung der Rechte im LED schädlich
zur durchsuchen bei ihm sagte die Justiz
macht ihren Job ich habe nichts zu
verbergen Eva kaii noch Vizepräsidentin
bleibt inhaft ihr Vater kommt frei die
Polizei hatte ihn festgenommen als er
dieses Hotel verließ den Koffer voll
Geld die eu-botschaft von Katar twittert
jede Verbindung mit diesen Vorwürfen
entbehrt jeder Grundlage und beruhta
Fehlinformationen die
kommissionspräsidentin zeigte sich am
Mittag besorgt
ich schlage vor eine unabhängige
ethikstelle einzurichten zuständig für
alle EU-Institutionen andere wollen das
Transparenzregister auf
drittstaatenausweiten die
Sozialdemokraten Zweifeln am nutzen wir
haben hier einen Fall dass wir wirklich
jemanden haben der kriminelle Energie
hat der würde ja auch niemals
reinschreiben ins transparente Geister
ich habe 600.000 Euro von Katar bekommen
es ist die Suche nach Lösungen bevor das
ganze Ausmaß des Skandals bekannt ist
ja und wieso was überhaupt möglich sein
kann und was für Schritte man jetzt
ergreifen muss darüber sprechen wir
jetzt mit Michelle van Hilton er ist
Geschäftsführer der Organisation
transparerity international EU guten
Abend Herr von Hilton
guten Abend
Herr von Hütten das was da an illegale
Einflussnahme gerade ans Licht kommt ist
das in ihren Augen ein krasser
Einzelfall oder steckt da was
systemisches dahinter
ich denke das ist so ein bisschen was
von beiden das ist der größte Skandal
den es je gegeben hat in Brüssel im
Europäischen Parlament ich habe so etwas
zuvor noch nie gesehen und es ist
unwahrscheinlich dass mehrere dieser
Dinge gleichzeitig passieren aber man
muss auch sagen das ist ein Problem im
puncto Transparenz und Integrität gibt
in den europäischen Institutionen und
dem EU-Parlament insbesondere und seit
langem rufen wir als transparente
international dazu auch bessere Regeln
und besser durchgesetzte Regeln
einzuführen wenn es ein Klima gibt wo
Korruption
und
Einflussnahme
toleriert wird dann ist natürlich
schwieriger das was passiert
wir haben das jetzt gerade in dem einen
Spieler schon gesehen es gibt Menschen
die fordern wir brauchen jetzt eine Art
ethik-gremium ein übergreifendes Gremium
was für alle EU-Organe zuständig ist
dann gibt es Stimmen die werden laut die
sagen es gibt ja in der EU schon ein
Transparenzregister wir müssen das
Ausweiten auf
illegale Einflussnahme von Drittstaaten
was glauben Sie denn was ist der
richtige Weg gerade um für mehr
Transparenz zu sorgen
wir denken auf jeden Fall dass externe
unabhängige Aufsicht wichtig ist und das
hätte man schon lange haben sollen Frau
von der Leyen die kommissionspräsidentin
hat das ja schon vor drei Jahren
vorgeschlagen aber der Vorschlag die
hängen in den Institutionen weil keiner
das durchsetzen will wir warten jetzt
darauf dass die Europäische Kommission
einen konkreten Vorschlag macht und wir
sprechen ja auch mit den
Mitglieder des Europäischen Parlaments
viele haben das noch blockiert bis vor
kurzem aber jetzt unterstützen Sie es
wie müssen wir uns das denn vorstellen
jetzt kommt quasi so ein Skandal ans
Licht und auf einmal gibt es quasi
Unterstützung für so einen Vorschlag der
in den letzten Jahren nicht bei allen
Anklang gefunden hat woran lag das dass
das bisher nicht so ganz oben auf der
Agenda lag
ich denke niemand will zu sehr Aufsicht
über die eigene Arbeit sehen das kann
natürlich anstrengend sein wenn man
immer die richtigen Berichte publizieren
muss und dass man immer auf
informationswebseiten entsprechend
publiziert wird und die Öffentlichkeit
über die eigenen Treffen mit anderen
informieren muss aber das muss passieren
damit die Bürger auch wissen wie
Gesetzgeber und gemacht wird das ist
leicht nicht angenehm aber es ist
notwendig um die Integrität des
politischen Systems aufrecht zu halten
und auch das Vertrauen darin aufrecht zu
halten
ja apropos vertrauen wir stellen ja auch
hier Fragen aus unserer Community und
ich sehe hier auch Fragen in denen es um
die grundsätzliche Arbeit von Politikern
PolitikerInnen auf EU-Ebene geht YouTube
User icke fragt hat Kylie eine Art Eid
gebrochen muss sie am Anfang ihrer
Karriere dort quasi sowas wie ein Eid
ablegen wie funktioniert das
ja
auf jeden Fall
alle Mitglieder des Europäischen
Parlaments müssen einen Verhaltenskodex
unterschreiben und müssen versprechen
dass sie solche Aktivitäten nicht
durchführen sie hat also dieses
Versprechen gebrochen und es gibt solche
Regeln im Parlament aber die die der
Bruch der Regeln wird nicht verfolgt und
es hat einige dieser Fälle in den
letzten Jahren gegeben aber es gab keine
Konsequenzen wenn das die europäischen
Abgeordneten wissen dann wissen sie es
gibt keine Abschreckung gegenüber
solchen illegalen Aktivitäten bei den
Aktivität
die sind sicherlich eine Einzelfall und
dieser Aktivität jetzt nicht
repräsentativ für das was im
Europäischen Parlament passiert oder in
Brüssel
ja also wir hören hier noch mal unseren
Experten der auch noch mal einordnet wie
groß dieser Skandal ist und wie
außergewöhnlich vielleicht auch und
erste Reaktionen aus dem EU-Parlament
auf diese Geschehnisse die hat uns ultra
mal zusammengefasst
70 Jahre europäische Demokratie der
stolze Satz steht noch an der Fassade
vor wenigen Wochen feierten sie den 70
geburtstag des EU-Parlaments und nun
lastet der Vorwurf der Bestechlichkeit
auf den Abgeordneten das Parlament gibt
sich kämpferisch
zeigt euch nicht das Europäische
Parlament wird angegriffen die
europäische Demokratie wird angegriffen
vor allem die europäischen
Sozialdemokraten von S&D stehen im Fokus
aus ihren Reihen kommen die Verdächtigen
und die Festgenommenen
Problem ist ich glaube das systemisches
Problem der Angriff Katars das
Europa-Parlament zieht Konsequenzen die
angedachte Visa Erleichterung für
Kataris die nach Europa reisen wollen
sind wohl vom Tisch
es ist so dass ich nicht davon ausgehe
das total in den nächsten Jahren
irgendeine Chance haben sollte eine
dieser Liberalisierung zu bekommen erste
Abgeordnete stellen nun das Gasabkommen
zwischen Deutschland und Katar in frage
ich finde es eigentlich schwer
vorstellbar dass wir
Lieferverträge eingehen dass wir neue
Abhängigkeiten Schaffen von Staaten die
die international so agieren
einer freut sich über den Skandal Viktor
Orban der ungarische Regierungschef
selbst von der EU wegen Korruption
kritisiert wirft er dem EU-Parlament auf
Twitter Scheinheiligkeit vor
man versucht die Situation auszunutzen
aber ich denke an die Menschen in Ungarn
überhaupt niemanden haben der sie vor
Korruption schützt
ihr Stuhl blieb heute leer Eva kailli
die Vizepräsidentin sitzt in
Untersuchungshaft und alle fragen sich
ob da noch mehr kommt
ja wir haben es eben im Beitrag gehört
diese Art von Korruption wird wirklich
auch als Angriff auf den europäisches
wichtiges Organ auf die europäische
Demokratie gewertet Herr van hüllten wie
sehen Sie das denn welche langfristigen
Schäden kann so ein Skandal vielleicht
auch in das Vertrauen der Bürger haben
letztendlich ist das EU-Parlament ja die
einzige gewählte Vertretung von Bürgern
auf EU-Ebene
das ist genau richtig das ist wirklich
sehr sehr schädlich und
2024 kommen ja den nächsten Europawahlen
und es ist im Interesse des Europäischen
Parlaments dass da wirklich Ordnung
herrscht wir müssen natürlich ganz klar
sagen wie das auch heute im Parlament
gesagt wurde das ist eine gefährliche
Einflussnahme durch ausländische durch
ausländische Akteure wenn Kata dahinter
steckt ist das wirklich zu verurteilen
und man muss solche Attacken auf die
demokratische Situation Institution der
EU stoppen aber das EU-Parlament muss
sicherstellen dass dort Ordnung herrscht
dass die richtige Regeln existieren in
Bezug auf glaube wegen dass es Verhalten
sie gibt damit das nicht mehr passieren
kann in der Zukunft das Parlament muss
das zwischen heute und 20 und 24 einfach
in Ordnung bringen
wir haben hier noch mal eine Frage aus
unserer Community die ich so ein
bisschen mehr an dem System dahinter
orientiert weil es ist ja auch
kompliziert es gibt zum einen
Einflussnahme es gibt Lobbyismus der
auch legal ist es gibt illegale
Einflussnahme das ist das was wir jetzt
hier gerade erleben und YouTube User
Carlo Zero fragt wie kann man denn
Gesetze schaffen die Lobbyismus besser
von Korruption abgrenzen sollte nicht
eher Lobbyismus ganz stark eingeschränkt
werden
das ist eine sehr gute Frage die wir
auch sehr oft hören aber das würde ich
jetzt nicht sagen im Prinzip ist der
Lobbyismus ja etwas Positives so gut
dass wenn das verantwortungsbewusst
gemacht wird
man denkt immer an große Firmen viel
Geld zu wie im Fall dieses Landes aber
es gibt auch Bürger
Bürgerbewegungen oder NGOs das sind ja
auch Glaube ist und so kann man eben zu
besseren politischen Entscheidungen
führen wir müssen das Positive am
Lobbyismus und unterstützen und das
illegale am Lobbyismus dass wir auch
sehen dass das angegriffen wird und
gestoppt wird das existiert ja auch in
der Minderheit
ja danke Herr van Hilton für diesen
expertenblick auf einen sehr komplexes
Thema vielen Dank dass Sie bei uns waren
diese Fälle sorgen gerade richtig krass
für Aufmerksamkeit weil sie in dem bis
jetzt bekannten Ausmaß eben so groß sind
es ist aber nicht der erste Fall von
Korruption den es auf dieser Ebene gab
welche Fälle ist da bisher gab und worum
es da ging das hat Thomas Gonsior mal
für uns zusammengefasst
dunkle Machenschaften wuchernde
Korruption damit muss ich 2003
EU-Kommissionspräsident Romano pro die
Beschäftigen es geht um die sogenannte
Eurostat-Affäre das Statistikamt der EU
sollen in den 90er Jahren fiktive
Aufträge vergeben Millionen an Euro in
schwarze Kassen überführt haben 3 €
statt Chefs werden entlassen
2012 John Dalli soll EU-Bürger schützen
auch vor Gefahren des Rauchens
stattdessen
Korruptionsvorwürfe der maltesische EU
gesundheitskommissar soll von einer
tabakfirma Geld verlangt haben um eine
EU Tabak Richtlinie zu entschärfen Dalli
tritt zurück ebenfalls 2012 die
aserbaidschan-affäre im Fokus der
Europarat für Abgeordnete finanzierte
Aserbaidschan Luxus Reisen teure
Gastgeschenke inklusive und zahlte Geld
als Gegenleistung oder Verdacht
beurteilte der CSU Europarat Abgeordnete
Eduard Lindner Wahlen dort als positiv
trotzdem weisen auf Wahl Fälschungen
ebenso Karin strenz die mittlerweile
verstorbene CDU Wahl beobachteten
stimmte außerdem gegen die Forderung des
Rats politische Gefangene in
Aserbaidschan freizulassen Bestechung
durch Aserbaidschan die Aufklärung
schleppend
Ausnahme der italienische Abgeordnete
Luca volonté er wurde verurteilt wegen
Korruption zu vier Jahren Gefängnis
ja das mal als kleinen Rückblick in die
Geschichte wir wollen jetzt aber darüber
sprechen wie EU-Abgeordnete diesen
Skandal in den eigenen Reihen erleben
und darüber spreche ich jetzt mit Erik
Marquardt EU-Abgeordneter und Teil der
grünen Fraktion und Daniel Caspari
ebenfalls die EU-Abgeordneter und Teil
der Fraktion der Europäischen
Volkspartei wenn ihr Fragen an die
beiden habt oder einfach Anmerkungen zum
Thema dann schickt sie hier gerne in den
Chat oder per Mail an ZDF heute- live
zdf.de Herr Marquardt sie sind ja selber
im Ausschuss für bürgerliche Freiheiten
Justiz und Inneres in dem hat Eva kaii
am ersten Dezember über die eben
angesprochenen Visa Erleichterung für
Kataris abgestimmt obwohl sie selber gar
nicht Mitglied im Ausschuss ist wie
haben Sie denn diese Abstimmung da
erlebt wie müssen wir uns das vorstellen
ich frage mich jetzt fällt das nicht auf
wenn da jemand sitzt der da eigentlich
nicht sitzen soll
das ist grundsätzlich nicht ganz
ungewöhnlich dass auch Abgeordnete einer
Fraktion Menschen die dann nicht da sein
können vertretenen Ausschüssen also
nicht ganz unüblich das Abgeordnete
nicht Mitglied im Ausschuss sind aber
abstimmt was natürlich in diesem ganzen
Kontext in dem was wir jetzt die letzten
Tage gelernt haben sehr auffällt ist
dass ich verteidig sich ganz besonders
für Katar eingesetzt hat und das war
auch vorher schon einige Leute
aufgefallen dass das mit Korruption
zusammenhängt weil er eben erst seit
kurzem
Herr Kaspari wir haben es eben schon
angesprochen es gibt Einflussnahme und
es gibt illegale Einflussnahme das sind
zwei verschiedene Dinge erklären Sie uns
das mal wie müssen wir uns das
vorstellen wenn da Interessenvertretung
oder Lobbyismus auf EU-Ebene passiert wo
treten diese Menschen an sie heran wie
läuft das normalerweise ab als
EU-Abgeordneter
ja gut wie gesagt wird ja vorhin auch
deutlich im Interview ihr Lobbyismus
gehört dazu dass Unternehmen Verbände
Gewerkschaften Kirchen Verbände nicht
Regierungsorganisationen andere Staaten
ihre Interessen uns Abgeordneten
entgegenbringen ist Bestandteil der
Demokratie und auf der Basis von
möglichst vielen Informationen wollen
wir dann ja auch unsere Entscheidungen
treffen und alles ist legal verkürzt und
für einfach solange einfach Dinge offen
und transparent an uns angebracht werden
der Volkswagen Lobby ist da steht
Volkswagen auf der Visitenkarte ich weiß
wer ihn bezahlt ich weiß was sein
Interesse ist und das ist alles in
Ordnung aber was eben einfach
illegal ist ist wenn sich ein
Abgeordneter für Tätigkeiten bezahlen
lässt und der Vorwurf der ja im Raum
steht ist das ganz konkret die Kollegin
im Ausschuss so abgestimmt hat wie sie
es hat gegen Geld dass sie inhaltlich
reden bei uns im Parlament gehalten hat
gegen Geld und wenn diese Vorwürfe sich
bewahrheiten dann ist eben das genau der
illegale teil und was uns denke ich alle
hier im Parlament ärgert ich bin der
festen Überzeugung die aller
allermeisten wir haben hier zwar
unterschiedliche Meinungen aber wir
kämpfen für das was wir fürs richtig
gehalten im Interesse der Menschen in
Europa und auf der Welt und das dann
einzelne schwarze Schafe hier das ganze
Parlament und wieder uns alle
Abgeordneten im mistkredit bringen das
ist der Flurschaden den wir hier gerade
alle mit Schrecken zur Kenntnis nehmen
müssen
ja das sind auf jeden Fall klare Worte
das wird mit Schrecken zu Kenntnis
genommen Herr Marquardt was muss denn in
ihren Augen das EU-Parlament jetzt für
Maßnahmen ergreifen um diesen Schaden
quasi noch so gut wie möglich abzuwenden
oder ihn so klein wie möglich zu halten
der erste Punkt ist natürlich Aufklärung
wir müssen als EU-Parlament aber
sicherlich auch die anderen die
Institutionen müssen schauen dass alles
auf den Tisch kommt dass wir gucken
welche Ausmaße hat dieser Skandale
eigentlich dann können wir auch die
richtigen Antworten finden was aber
jetzt schon klar ist dass ich glaube es
ist ein Untersuchungsausschuss geben
sollte und das auch Forderungen die
schon lange bestehen also zum Beispiel
dass man auch Treffen mit
Regierungsvertretern von Drittstaaten
öffentlich bekannt geben muss dass das
jetzt alles schnell kommen kann es gibt
also kurzfristige Antworten die wir
geben können es gibt aber auch
mittelfristige Antworten wo es sich
lohnt jetzt erstmal die Ermittlung
abzuwarten und dann wirklich die
richtigen auch harten Konsequenzen zu
ziehen
Herr Marquardt nee Herr Caspari mit
Herrn Marquardt habe ich gerade
gesprochen die sind ja auch Chef der CDU
csu-gruppe im EU-Parlament und haben
unter anderem gesagt sie sind
fassungslos darüber was ich in der
sozialdemokratischen Fraktion abgespielt
haben soll die beiden Fälle über die wir
jetzt gesprochen haben sind ja Teil der
sozialdemokratischen Fraktionen jetzt
ist ja aber die kommissionspräsidentin
Ursula von der Leyen die jetzt diesen
Ethikrat fordert auch Teil der cdu/csu
Gruppe wir haben es eben schon gehört
das erste Mal wurde dieser integrad vor
drei Jahren gefordert und jetzt kommt er
wieder zur Sprache warum kann denn da
bisher nicht mehr
ja wissen Sie dieser Ethikrat ein
solches Gremium hat Vor- und Nachteile
und da muss man ich denke in aller Ruhe
darüber sprechen denn wir Abgeordnete
haben in der Demokratie eine ganz
besondere Rolle wir sind die Vertreter
des Volkes und dass wir internen
Kontrolle brauchen ist klar aber ist es
sinnvoll dass frei gewählte Abgeordnete
von externen Dritten kontrolliert werden
ich denke da sollte man in aller Ruhe
darüber reden und alle Kontrolle die
auch über den Ethik gerade im Raum steht
hätten ja das was Kollegin kayli
vorgeworfen wird nicht verhindert sie
wollte einfach
illegal sich hier bereichern und wie
gesagt wenn die Vorwürfe stimmen da
hilft keine transparenzregel da hilft
kein Ethikrat und gar nichts und
deswegen wir stehen hier alle in dem
Dilemma das Transparent gut tut ich
halte es für eine grundsätzlich gute
Idee zum Beispiel Regierungen von
Drittstaaten bei uns in das Lobby
Register aufzunehmen auf der einen Seite
auf der anderen Seite ich habe selbst
schon Gesetzgebung erlebt wo Vertreter
von Firmen nicht mit mir reden wollten
weil es um Gesetzgebung ging die
bestimmte Länder getroffen hat und die
Unternehmen hatten dann Angst mit mir
darüber zu reden wenn ich dann quasi
veröffentlichen musste dass ich mit
ihnen gesprochen habe weil sie dann in
dem Land Gegenmaßnahmen oder Nachteile
durch die Regierung gefürchtet haben und
deswegen wir brauchen Transparenz davon
lebt Demokratie auf der anderen Seite
gibt es Bereiche wenn es darum geht
Missstände aufzudecken Whistleblower zu
schützen wo wir eben Ausnahmen brauchen
und deswegen sehen Sie was auf den
ersten Blick vollkommen klar scheint
wenn man sich genauer anschaut ist
leider etwas komplizierter aber klar ist
wir brauchen hier jetzt eine Diskussion
über alles aber wir sollten es wie
gesagt in Ruhe tun keine Vorstellungen
Entscheidungen treffen sondern eben die
Vor- und Nachteile abwägen
Herr Marquardt wie stehen sie denn zu
der Idee eines Ethikrats sehen Sie da
auch so gravierende Nachteile wie Herr
Kaspari
Caspari hat ja nicht so Nachteile
genannt sondern auch Chancen und ich
denke dass es sinnvoll ist diesen
Ethikrat einzurichten und dass man dann
darüber diskutieren kann wie schafft man
es denn dass er so ausgestaltet ist dass
er auch die richtigen trifft und dass er
damit am Ende effizient arbeitet also da
bin ich wirklich sehr hoffnungsvoll dass
auch parteiübergreifend zwischen den
verschiedenen Fraktionen dann
Diskussionen stattfinden wo man sich
auch zeichnen kann um zu gucken haben
wir da alles gedacht damit dieser
Ethikrat dann auch gut funktioniert und
das tut was er tun soll einfach schnell
ein Gremium zu schaffen dass dann
scheinbar vielleicht Probleme löst die
ist wenn man nicht gut drüber
nachgedacht hat er nicht löst dass es
sicherlich nicht hilfreich als ich habe
das gar nicht so verstanden dass er
jetzt vollständig dagegen war oder wird
dann jetzt sehr unterschiedliche
Position haben
nee dann habe ich mich falsch
ausgedrückt also es ist natürlich ein
Abwägen ich wollte nur fragen ob sie das
jetzt auch nachvollziehen können wir
haben jetzt ganz ich kann auch sagen
dass ich eine unterschiedliche Meinung
habe mit Herrn Kaspari vielleicht also
ich glaube dass die Transparenz zum
Beispiel bei den Regierungen mit
Drittstaaten dann wird jetzt viel gesagt
also das verhindert ja nicht dass jemand
Geld annimmt aber man hat zumindest dann
erstmal einen Hinweis welche Abgeordnete
treffen sich denn ganz besonders oft mit
bestimmten Vertretern und dann kann man
eben auch Fragen stellen kann
Journalismus auch Fragen stellen und
sagen warum treffen sie sich also so
eine Angst natürlich nicht dass man
nicht im Einzelfall auch begründen kann
warum man sich mit bestimmten Vertretern
auftrifft einfach Lobbyismus zu
verteufeln bringt nichts ich habe zum
Beispiel in den Kontext haben mich auch
mit jugendwatch die international
unterhalten das sind ja auch in dem
Sinne Lobby Organisation die aber dann
auch Menschenrechte fokussiert sind also
da muss man glaube ich auch schauen dass
man nicht Lobbyismus als solchen
verteufelt aber man kann eben schauen
wer trifft sich eigentlich mit welchen
Leuten das sollte viel transparenter
werden
genau zu dem Punkt Herr Marquardt man
kann ja die Dinge eben nur dann
nachverfolgen wenn sie angegeben werden
und genau das ist der Punkt ist sie und
ich so wie ich sie kenne wir würden die
Dinge transparent angeben weil wir hier
ich glaube recht schaffende Abgeordnete
sind aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen
dass die Kollegin Kylie auch nur einen
Termin mit irgendjemand angegeben hätte
der sie in ein schlechtes Licht gerückt
hätte oder der eben genau diese
Nachfragen produziert hätten und das ist
genau das Problem wie schaffen wir eben
Transparenz in der Demokratie nötig ist
wie schränken wir auf der anderen Seite
die rechtschaffenden Abgeordneten in
ihrer Tätigkeit nicht ein und auf der
dritten Seite ihr das was wir hier
erleben ist Korruption und die hätte
kein Ethikrat geholfen hätte keine
transparenzregel geholfen ist sondern
wer hier wirklich
illegale Machenschaften macht sich
bereichern will da brauchen wir wirklich
intelligente Antworten und wie gesagt
deswegen ist die Abwägung wo wir glaube
ich einfach nur über Details der
Marquardt sprechen müssen weil im Kern
haben wir das gleiche Ziel wir wollen
einen Parlament des transparent arbeitet
und in dem die Bürgerinteressen zu Wort
kommen und nicht die Interessen von
demjenigen der hier irgendjemanden
bezahlt
ja Herr Marquardt sie haben es gerade
schon angesprochen Journalisten und
Journalistin würden sich sicher freuen
über mehr Transparenz wir haben ja aber
gerade auch noch eine Frage aus der
Community von Martin Schmidt auf Youtube
der fragt warum muss es keine
Offenlegung der Lobbyisten Treffen geben
für die Wähler wieso müssen die das
eigentlich nicht offenlegen wenn es
direkt Gewitter Vertreter sind
man muss Lobbyisten treffen angegeben da
gibt es Regeln zu dass man die auch auf
der Homepage veröffentlicht das sieht
man auch kann man auch die Abgeordneten
Seiten gehen und dann sind doch treffen
angegeben aber eben nur mit zivilen
Organisationen nicht z.B wenn man sich
mit trittstaat
Botschaftern unterhält oder mit einem
Minister aus einem Drittstaat und das
ist genau das was ich glaube was
geändert werden sollte dass man eben ja
viel mehr in dieser Treffen angibt nicht
weil man dadurch verhindern kann das
einzelne recht Lügen schon sehen kann
mensch trifft sich im Parlament doch
gerade mit dem katarischen Botschafter
wird das überhaupt angegeben wenn sie
dann üben will kann sie das tun aber es
fällt eben viel schneller auch wenn sie
dazu verpflichtet wäre solche Treffen
anzugeben
ja wir haben jetzt viel über Eva Kylie
gesprochen neben ihr rückt ja aber auch
gerade der sozialdemokratische
EU-Abgeordnete Markt tarabella in den
Fokus und vielleicht ist es ganz gut wir
haben uns noch mal angucken wie so was
dann wirklich konkret aussieht Herr
tarabella war vor einiger Zeit noch
großer Kritiker in einer WN in Katar
hörte sich dann aber zwischenzeitlich
sogar mal so an
natürlich ist die Situation in Katar
nicht perfekt da gibt's noch viel zu tun
aber das Land ist auf dem Weg der
Reformen daher sind diese einseitigen
negativen Äußerungen von heute für die
künftige Entwicklung der Rechte in Katha
schädlich
Herr Marquardt was haben Sie denn
gedacht als sie das das erste mal gehört
haben das ist ja schon recht deutlicher
Kurswechsel fragt man sich da schon was
hinter den Kulissen dann passiert
ja es ist ja leider so dass wir als
Abgeordneten nicht die ganze Zeit den
plenariäten Folgen können wenn sie
stattfinden werden parallelausschuss
Sitzung andere treffen Verhandlung über
andere Gesetzesentwürfe so dass in der
Regel die meisten Abgeordneten nicht die
Debatten zu Themen verfolgen wo sie
nicht selbst involviert sind wie bei
dieser Resolution was damit sagen will
ist ich persönlich habe die Reden von
marktkarabella und auch Eva kaii zu der
Situation in Katar erst gesehen als
diese Vorwürfe bekannt wurden und diese
reden dann durch die sozialen Medien
gehen
ja es gibt wahnsinnige wahnsinnig viele
Reden natürlich zu verschiedenen Themen
genauso wie Mark carabella war aber auch
Eva Kylie zuständig für Beziehungen zu
arabischen Halbinsel und dafür sie dann
unter anderem mit solchen Äußerungen auf
die WM in Katar ist heute der Beweis
dafür für die sportdiplomatie einen
historischen Wandel in einem Land
bewirken kann dennoch rufen einige jeder
dazu auf die Katara zu diskriminieren
sie schikanieren sie und beschuldigen
jeden der mit ihnen spricht der
Korruption
ja das haben wir noch mal gesehen auf
jeden Fall eindrückliche Äußerungen ich
habe hier noch eine Frage aus der
Community und zwar fragt music passer so
ein bisschen mit Deutschland Bezug die
EU hat immerhin ein Transparenzregister
wie steht es um mögliche Korruption im
Bundestag es gibt natürlich im Bundestag
ein Lobbyregister aber wie würden sie
das denn im Vergleich zum
Transparenzregister der EU bewerten Herr
Kaspari
ja wir sind beim Europäischen Parlament
ich denke so weit wie fast kein anderes
Parlament und definitiv weiter als der
Deutsche Bundestag ich möchte aber da
jetzt im Deutschen Bundestag gar keine
Empfehlung geben sondern das sollen die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen dort machen und
sie sehen bei uns auch wenn wir sehr
weit sind zum einen auch bei uns gibt es
offensichtlich Redebedarf wie müssen wir
die Regeln bei uns weiterentwickeln und
auf der anderen Seite obwohl die Regeln
mit die besten in Europa sind gibt es
Kollegen in dem Fall die sich nicht dran
halten anscheinend oder offensichtlich
so und deshalb ich möchte da nicht über
andere reden sondern ich denke unsere
Aufgabe ist hier zu schauen gibt es
weitere Fälle wer hat hier noch
irgendwas zu verbergen gibt es Dinge die
wir hier im Parlament besser machen
müssen und wie entwickeln wir die
europäische Demokratie weiter und
Vertrauen zurück zu gewinnen
ja und Stichwort europäische Demokratie
vielleicht noch eine abschließende Frage
an Sie Herr Marquardt wir haben nämlich
eine Frage von Uwe Hoffmann per Mail der
Fracht ist denn davon auszugehen dass
auch andere Staaten also zum Beispiel
Russland oder China durch Bestechung
versuchen Einfluss auf die Uhr zu nehmen
ich glaube schon dass dieser Skandal
dazu führen sollte dass die europäischen
Institution also das Europäische
Parlament aber auch die Kommission und
auch die Mitgliedsstaaten durchaus sich
anschauen wie gefährlich ist denn
eigentlich diese Einflussnahme von
Drittstaaten wir wissen dass
beispielsweise Russland und China
versuchen auch die europäische
Demokratie Einfluss zu nehmen und man
muss sich ich denke auch im Bundestag
genau angucken warum beispielsweise die
AFD die ja auf dem Verdacht steht dann
zumindest Teil finanziert zu sein durch
vielleicht Personen die dann ja einfach
Verbindung zu Russland haben warum sie
eigentlich zu russlandfreundliche
Position vertritt also ich glaube schon
dass man auch durch diesen Skandal jetzt
natürlich die Hausaufgaben und darauf
werden wir uns konzentrieren als
Europa-Parlamentarier im Europäischen
Parlament machen muss das aber auch die
anderen Institution auch die nationalen
Parlamente jetzt sehr genau gucken
müssen wie können wir verhindern dass
unsere Demokratie durch Korruption durch
Einflussnahme von Drittstaaten
angegriffen wird
ja wir bleiben bei ZDF heute live auf
jeden Fall weiter dran vielen Dank Herr
Marquardt vielen Dank Herr Caspari dass
Sie bei uns waren unsere Fragen
beantwortet haben und Stellung bezogen
haben danke an euch da draußen für eure
Kommentare und Mails wir bleiben auf
jeden Fall für euch dran und sehen uns
wieder bei ZDF heute live schönen Abend
noch